Try to stop the video
to calculate how much is 71 plus 24.
Okay, let's do that together.
Let's think what it means.
We have 1 in the order of the units.
Let it become clear.
This is the order of the units and we have one unit.
This is this one unit.
And then in the order of the dozen
we have 7, which means we have 7 groups of 10.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 groups of 10.
Therefore, this actually means 7 tenths and one unit.
Here they are - 71 squares.
We will now add 2 tens.
We will add 2 tens,
you see them here.
One tenth, two tenths and four units.
And 4 units.
So how much is it?
Let's first look at the units.
We have one unit and another 4 units.
This makes 5 units.
This makes 5 units,
and we can count them here.
Here are 5 units.
One unit plus 4 units is equal to 5 units.
Now look at the dozens -
7 tenths plus 2 tenths.
Or if we unite all these groups,
if we unite all these groups,
we will receive 9 groups of 10.
We'll have 9 tens.
7 tens and 2 tenths equals 9 tens.
So there are nine decades left.
As we can see here, there are 5 units.
And 5 units.
And how else could we say 9 tens
and 5 units?
We say that this is the number 95 and we are ready.